it's Ford's intended receiver
mouths forced DeRosa
to the left
not the best on fast break but I love
the results there for thirst gives it to
DeMar DeRozan inspace-3 except at the
start tonight six points they're led by
Wiggins with 10 here is DeRozan kicks
out Thomas Pratap
[Applause]
damar just drawing in a crowd and you
see Derrick Rose caught in no man's land
doesn't want to leave his man but I'll
have to think about that one I'll come
up with it 48:46 another early on in the
ballgame in the roses with Wiggins on
him
[Music]
just took his time with the big man oh
this one the book oh he has it but you
can see tomorrow working actually we
have just switched off with and Botox
gives it up to
DeMar DeRozan plus pounds got to be at
least and uses all that whatever he's
going for the preseason but he's covered
to play LaMarcus in the vicinity and
they're de Vargas gets physical with
Jimmy Butler who's not a lightweight by
the way backs him up a beautiful use of
the glass nice touch by Jabbar by the
way backs him up
a beautiful use of the glass nice touch
by depart